bienvenue sur under dogs le podcast
envergure qui comme son nom l'indiqué
vous présentent les profils de joueurs
qui ne font pas la une chérie est plein
mais qui pourrait avoir une belle
carrière en étant drafté en fin de
second tour voire mon graphe tic je
cherche les très grandes villes d'agde
et marc gasol nikola djokic pas
s'immiscer dans d'autres länder dogs ses
impôts de classe produit par la date
accident verdure nous sommes sept et à
chaque podcast trois d'entre vous vous
présentez un prospect de son choix et de
la zone dans titre récup monde europe ou
conférences m6 en guest on accueille un
membre d'envergure potes qui donnera un
indic point de vue sur chaque roue ce
que des présentations sont faites
c'est parti salut à tous
29 juillet retenez bien cette date car
c'est celle de la draft nba 2021 et
envergure sera évidemment de la partie
d'ici là beaucoup de prospects à
décrypter on se retrouve donc pour un
nouvel épisode de noise aujourd'hui pour
m'accompagner non pas deux non pas trois
mais quatre chroniqueurs vous connaissez
bien les deux premiers étaient présents
lors du premier podcast
il ya un mois c'est lui qui joue bien
qui sont là bonsoir messieurs bonsoir
c'est l'oeil de la data team pour toute
la zone europe
pierre et la salle pierre salut les gars
enfin il nous fallait la caution
envergure on imagine avec son col roulé
entouré de meubles massifs
on peut le dire luca dont six du
scouting à la lutte avec la cdu allen
merci beaucoup à coeur je suis très
content et en bout messieurs les
présentations sont faites sans plus
attendre
hunter 2 e saison 1 épisode 2 c'est
parti
[Musique]
on va commencer avec toi on va pas très
loin on va dans un pays frontalier
il est battable me joue pour une équipe
belge je te laisse prononcer le nom du
joueur quand tu vas nous présentait donc
ce soir on a parlé de quai van der geest
de wirth normalement déjà bravo merci ça
prend ça prend quelques quelques jours
mais vous en avez sûrement besoin pourra
les années à venir qui globalement donc
c'est un jeune néerlandais qui est né en
décembre 2001 donc il a 19 ans c'est un
meneur droitier et depuis 2010 est il
joue à ostende donc en belgique et il
est sous contrat jusqu'en 2023
donc on se dirige sur meneur
gestionnaire qui va surtout brillé par
sa vision du jeu et sa distribution
voilà huit points cinq points par match
en ligue belge à 4 2 assists 2,6 ballon
perdu par match avec des pourcentages
qui se rend ma foi comme nabeul 48% 48%
à 3 point à 78 % aux lancers francs est
donc totale à 176 22 2% de yusei dont
c'est le troisième dans l'équipe alors
qu'il sort du banc passe derrière
djordjevic et si la dent a déjà parlé
sur l'envergure est par contre une
petite stat qui peuvent faire froncer
les sourcils 28% de turnover alors bcl
le top 10 est souvent en dessous de 22
15 % d'accord donc là c'est pour les
côtés positifs et les côtés un peu
moins positifs à travailler on va dire
ben on est sur un garçon qui y va
vraiment brillé d'un seul côté du
terrain c'est à dire que en défense il a
il s'est pas vraiment c'est pas un fou
un chef ou en défense et patronaux qui
va verrouiller son défenseur le coller à
la culotte l'empêché d'avancer
il a des gros grosse grosse oubli sur
écran de retard il a pas beau pas au
bout de rebond je crois qu'il a 2
rebonds par match sur cette saison et
voilà comme j'ai dit quelques tendance à
perdre un petit peu le ballon parce que
c'est c'est un pass first et ça peut lui
jouer des tours c'est vraiment un mec
qui cher qui cherche à trouver le mec
démarquer à l'opposé derrière la tête et
ça peut parfois l'amener à envoyer des
patates chaudes quoi d'accord alan toi
qui es aux munitions tulle a forcément
vu excuses en france
je trouve que c'est un très bon passeur
ça va il fait des très belles poissons
et jouent bien pick and roll et je pense
que la nécessité comme l'a dit pierre
cessé de le voir dans plusieurs
contextes pour les prospects
internationaux
c'est bien les regarder dans les
championnats nationaux avec les équipes
de jeunes parce qu'on a vu que les rôles
changent et à sa pouvoir appuyer ce que
dit un peu pierre ça permet d' un peu
évolué dans différents contextes pierre
a mentionné brun qui défend des pas trop
bas c'est parce qu'en fait dans les
catégories jeunes avec les pays bas on
va prendre des bus était vraiment le
meilleur joueur c'était le créateur sans
lui il n'y a pas grand chose qui se
passe est donc en fait on ne faisait pas
défendre en faisant ont le masque est un
peu parce qu'il y avait toutes là la
lacra ce point ci va assumer problème
c'est que cette année il sort du banc de
résider comme les ambitions d'europe
donc il doit un peu plus défendre et il
y arrive pas trop serré chasser l'accord
du je n'ai pas trop vu défendre
après je trouve que c'est intéressant de
parler de lui et d'ostende parce que au
stand devant un peu le modèle légal ex
parce qu'ils ne savent pas c'est que
c'est ils ont décidé d'attirer des
prospects attirer des prospects peuvent
potentiellement prétendre à la nba ou
top niveau européen
donc avec ce monsieur dont je vais pas
prendre c'est le mot que j'appelle
témoin vv mais eux mais aussi mariona
kitsch et mars il a qui sont quand même
deux gros prospects du était brisée
qu'ils viennent du real madrid
donc c'est intéressant à voir et moi je
trouve cela super super bon passeur ou
bonjour de pick and roll il a pas encore
eu de tirs qui suivent trou
malheureusement mais un peu un peu un
peu nonchalant en défense mais un vrai
sens de la passe il ya un truc que je
sais que tu regarde beaucoup
très souvent quand tu regardes les
meneurs si la capacité à poulpe
qu'est-ce qui est ce que où est ce
qu'ils se situent ce garçon par rapport
à ça j'ai pas je n'ai pas trop vu gérard
de deux matchs et demi donc deux matchs
d'une mi-temps bcl j'ai pas pu voir de
l'hymne belge malheureusement j'ai pas
réussir à en trouver mais il plaît pas
trop ce samedi cherche vraiment vraiment
la passe et donc ça va on le défend ça
ça fait baisser son gravité en quelque
sorte de comment on va le défendre parce
qu'on attend la passe et donc on peut le
défendre un petit peu plus facilement
que si la lampe cela remet du poulpe
il arrive la forme et pas affreuse je
n'ai pas vu en mme et énormément dans
les matchs que je me suis je me suis
envoyé mais c'est pas encore trop trop
ça sur le bloc mais je pense que si pire
la plus vile appelé dieu tête même en
ligue belge pour être plus menaçant sur
ce point violents alors la ligue belge
sait pas c'est impossible carrément
quasiment à trouver sur sur internet
par contre ceux qui la catch and shoot
c'est vrai ce sera pas le joueur qui
jouera en catch and shoot jamais
sûrement seront jamais par contre il a
des stats intéressantes
il a il a 44 % à 3 points cette année il
ce qui me semble encourageant c'est que
tous ces shoots les prend au minimum à
un mètre de la ligne
et quand je dis minimum un mètre de la
ligne c qui lui prend vraiment un maître
le
le joueur s'attend vraiment parce qu'ils
le prennent et halal a dit la gestuelle
et la mécanique est pas mal et ce qui va
lui donner un avantage c'est vraiment ce
que capacité à être une menace à chaque
fois on passe qui va faire que les les
les autres joueurs sont toujours sur la
défensive avec lui ils savent pas ce
qu'il va faire c'est vraiment une menace
à tout moment sur pick and rolls et je
pense que c'est à son âge c'est assez
impressionnant dabou aussi fort de
comprendre aussi bien de faire des fêtes
de dfn de test mike smith mexique en
parlait avec l'âme et lobo l'année
dernière où il est vraiment capable de
regarder manipulation visuel ouais et à
vraiment dégagé en fait le dga dégager
le joueur qui est à l'opposé puisque son
défenseur va venir à venir compenser la
raquette et le trouvait quasiment à
chaque fois mais à la l'a dit c'est
vraiment vraiment c'est un esthète de la
passe c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
est magnifique
il arrive même à mettre des joueurs qui
sont ko compense pas en capacité de
marquer à un moment clé grâce à ses
passes qui va changer l'orientation du
jeu et rend permettra tout à tout le
monde de marquer on n'a pas trop parlé
de ses capacités physiques on sait que
pour les leviers c'est quelque chose qui
est important comment vous situez moi
j'ai un peut-être un test dès qu on
utilise ou dont parle pas souvent c'est
sa puberté il a presque sa pilosité
pardon il a presque pas de poils on voit
presque pas donc ça veut dire qu'il est
sûrement encore possible qu'ils les la
croissance musculaire
alors qu'il a déjà un joli corps elle
c'est intéressant ce n'est pas ma tasse
passé la pilosité des genres mais c'est
vrai
il a une tête de bombes ma passion pour
te rassurer moi ça fait 12 ans que j'ai
pas pris de pilosité pourtant mon
développement et définir mais tu vois
ces gens là j'ai pu en parler avec des
gens qui m'ont dit que voilà on pouvait
quand même car d'année sur ça et on voit
quand même les seniors ans les seniors
en dessous tu vois qu'ils ont tous deux
commencent à prendre la barre puis il
est vraiment un enfant ses livres il est
pas encore très développé il fait entre
80 et 85 kg je dirais il fait un mètre
quatre-vingt moins d'un mètre 95 ça
c'est sûr il le plus provient de 90
jours et voilà j'avais vu quatre l'état
91 lors de l'euro u18 b c'est en 2019 et
la prime de signature prendre deux
centimètres en deux ans donc c'est
quasiment deux ans pas c'est pas
exceptionnel mais le physique sera pas
un avantage ça c'est assez clair avec
moi ça limite le potentiel et demi donc
du coup sûr la projection comment vous
l'imaginez dans les années à venir
il reste en europe s'est tant sa chanson
r'n'b et ça passe pas un tout et dit moi
tout je veux commencer il ya une
interview intéressante sur sur le site
de la fiba pour ceux qui veulent à en
connaître un peu plus sur lui e
il dit qu'il s'inspire beaucoup de
facundo quand pato et personnellement je
le verrais bien avoir peut-être une
carrière à la fac ou non c'est à dire il
commence dans un club relativement petit
pour aller peut-être à après en
euroligue
il a vraiment des capacités sur
lesquelles il peut se se bâtir une
réputation je pense que mon père un
mineur qui est capable distribuer le jeu
comme ça ça va être ça peut être assez
recherché en europe jeu il y peu ce 3-1
se présenter à la draft jusqu'en 2023
ça lui laisse le temps de faire ses
preuves
peut-être pas à vous n'êtes pas de rapts
et mais je le vois bien peut-être faire
une ou deux se marient
qu'est ce que tu en penses à la je pense
que ses doigts la nba s'est il ira sur
la deuxième partie de sa vente de ce
compte il aura en pointant sa deuxième
partie de l'antenne après vingt-cinq
ouais parce que je pense qu'il faut
l'adapter
je pense que c'est un joueur qui doit me
matures et en europe année la c1 2001 il
le remplaçant dans une équipe moyenne de
becel rap il va y avoir passé des étapes
de titulaire dans une bonne équipe du
bcm peut-être jouer l'euro cup a
peut-être joué des rôles et il est déjà
international hollandais a donc honoré
avec l'équipe à il va alors prendre de
l'expérience
et s'il doit y aller je pense que ça
sera parce qu'il acquit acquis un gros
gros cuit et qui sait que c'est un des
meilleurs meneurs d'europe si jamais ça
se passe pour un rôle de backup comme ça
se fait des fois je façon que ça réussir
et messi doit s'il ya un chemin pour lui
ce serait plus ce chemin là je pense que
c'est le plus jeune international
néerlandais à jouer avec les seniors
d'accord julien a eu on vous a pas
entendu ce que vous et des remarques ou
des questions à faire ce soir si vous
l'avez vu t'avoue que que moi moi seul
truc que j'allais dire c'était qu'il me
faisait penser un petit peu pas
justement un facundo tu vas être mais la
coupe est comme ça sous le pied donc je
me suis dit mince ma seule bonne
comparaison et pièces un thème sur
lequel on va peut-être revenir au plus
tard sur d'autres jouent sera mesure
mais c'est vrai que être drafté au
second tour quand est important de balle
principal c'est difficile en nba
on voit par expérience qu'il ya très
très peu qui réussissent à s'imposer
dans une rotation sur le long terme à
faire carrière en étant drafté en tant
que porteur de balle au second tour et
donc effectivement pour ces jours là moi
je préfère qu'il fasse du chemin en
europe lui ont-ils et il est européen
donc c'est peut-être plus facile et qui
viennent s'il doit venir quand il sera
plus plus mûr julien
moi je suis d'accord avec tout ce que
vous avez dit ses qualités quoi c'est un
énorme pas sûr on a l'impression qu'ils
voient tous plus vite que les autres
vraiment sur le déroulement en attaque
c'est assez impressionnant et et je les
ai vus a envoyé des bombes à trois
points de service à part vite et il peut
shooter de très loin après ce qui est
assez étonnant avec son shoot c'est que
il est un peu les pieds dans le béton
quoi oui je souhaite centraux centraux
décoller les pieds et du coup je me
demande si si pour la jouer de pick and
rolls et si tu vois pas ne pas voir
d'explosion comme ça au shoot
ça peut ça peut être pénalisée sur le
pick and roll cas après il a une vision
incroyable pour faire les passes pour
trouver des liens déstabilise tout le
monde s'est tu
mais ce manque de d'explosion pour pour
le shoot pur pour l'instant je pense que
c'est compliqué après il manque
d'explosivité dans dans tous les
compartiments de jeu c'est pas un mec
qui va qui va laisser à quelqu'un sur le
banc cela prend de vitesse il va sur il
va souvent réussir à se créer des des
drive grâce à grâce aux pick and roll et
c'est pas un mec qui va aller je posais
oh oh certes life elle a même fait à peu
près la même taille que théo maledon et
qui à nice et moi j'ai jamais vue n'a
fait je n'ai pas vu d'un cas sur tous
les matches que j'ai vus fini très bas
il est un joueur horizontale quoi
kaspersky site des galeries horizontales
moment il n'y a pas de verticalité
parce qu'après on a des mecs qui peuvent
tirer sans sauter très haut tant que ça
parte vite quoi la juge moi je crois je
suis passé expert sur ce jour là mais
faut que ça part très très vite moi je
trouve qu'il a une qui donne une release
assez rapide après peut-être que alan
les expériences pour dire vrai je trouve
ça pas mal ça c'est pas c'est pas
magnifique hyper rapide mais c'est juste
je suis tombé sur des matches je n'ai
pas bien réussit donc c'est un peu un
peu problématique mieux mais j'ai vu la
même chose que passer à bouloc de loin
et pieds dans le ciment très d'accord
avec avec julien mathieu messieurs
a fait le tour sur calvin des amours de
monsieur lancé j'ai eu au moins c'est
bien être là on va partir maintenant
garé son retour audio aux usa
championnat ici
julien on va dans une ville chère à
kauai léonarde je veux vous parler d'un
poste cap qui joue pour les aztèques ce
cher à l'anoci mode mitchell matt
mitchell alors 4 ou 3 4 quoi ouais voilà
un nouveau joueur donc de san diego
state university c'est toujours la
montagne ouest mountain west conférence
donc j'ai pas reparlé de de la
conférence on en a déjà parlé dans
l'épisode 1 mais juste pour dire que
c'est une conférence qui est compacte
qui vous ya beaucoup de il ya des
joueurs qui sont tractés donc l'année
dernière il y en a - 4 je crois on en
avait parlé son équipe san diego state
une forte équipe depuis deux ans
l'année dernière c'est alors que j'avais
noté ca de 30 victoires 2 défaites voilà
contre contre une élevé et un site étant
en finale de la montagne noire et cette
année c'est 23,5 alors au niveau du jeu
de l'équipe
c'est une équipe qui est comme moi qui a
qui a évolué depuis l'année dernière
presque sont partis ils ont perdu leur
meneur phare en fait qui est qui a été
drafté par par toronto fin de 1er tour
mal acquis
mais la klein fragile ouais et c'est un
petit peu chamboulé l'équipe au début de
l'année c'était c'était ça a été comme
ça toute l'année en fait c'est plus
aussi fluide que ça l'était l'année
dernière ils ont trois majeurs en fête
qui tourne qui ont des qualités quand
même chacun mais qui n'ont pas là le jeu
de fini donc pourquoi j cesse parce que
ses impacts et comme je pense que le jeu
de 28 chez elle cette année donc matt
nix elle sait bien c'est un 3 4 qui joue
sous qui commence à jouer qui commence
les attaques souvent à l'extérieur
si un bon un bon ce coureur
universitaire qui est capable
alors il peut shooter il peut ensuite en
poule up il peut shooter à trois points
il peut driver il est un dribble très
correct se trouve pour sur des petits
petits espaces il ya encore alors il
faut quand même parler du physique parce
que je pense que sa cible qui est assez
important chez lui c'est un gars qui est
costaud quand lee costaud il fit plus de
100 kg 1
la 106 kilos pour 1 mètre 98
donc c'est un gros bébé qui comme très
mobiles et très souple et vif
il est un gars qui est capable de faire
des spins en pleine course c'est un gars
qui a un qui est très souple et là on
peut le dire il a un gros arrière train
c'est assez marrant je vais pas le gang
gros charte
voilà c'est ça ouais j'ai pas je vois
c'est ça j'ai pas son envergure je pense
que c'est assez correct elle est
positive et donc c'est un joueur qui
puissant et assez alors explosifs sans
être trop athlétique quoi donc ça c'est
pour le côté positif de la fêlée côté un
peu plus obscurs du personnage
je pense que ce qu'il faut qu'ils
travaillent c'est à tous d'accord moi
j'ai pas trouvé l'ouverture au monde le
donne en direct s'ils se disent ça fait
quoi c'était de m huit autres comme ça
ouais ouais c'est ça ouais donc sinon
voilà c'est bien c'est bien positif
encore un gars de deux mètres ce qui
donc au niveau des défauts assez en fait
il perd beaucoup de ballons il a il a un
ratio passe
turn over négatif c'est pas un très très
bon gros rebondeur et ça je pense que
c'est un peu un peu le pénalisée par
rapport à sa projection futur c'est pas
un très gros rebondeur et il prend
correctement de romo défensif très peu
de rebonds offensifs par contre il n'a
pas beaucoup delà des chiffres très
modeste au contre et parce que là il est
pas très content il va pas très très
haut
c'est un super raquette quoi donc il va
pas sauter païenne gravité du postérieur
quoi il est rattrapé par son postérieur
et puis pour tu vois tu présenter comme
un poste 4
chez moins de m donc ça peut être un
petit peu ça il pourra pas travailler
elle peut être un petit peu négatif pour
sa protection ok alan toi tu l'a
forcément vu parce que six universités
où qu'elles tellier de façon indirecte
je crois je suis obligé de regarder sans
dignité
non je serai pas d'héritage paternel mon
père ya étudié jouer au foot en fait
dans les années 90
soccer un pas tuer c'est donc je regarde
tous les matchs de énormément de matches
de san diego state j'ai évidemment que
le match contre syracuse le ce match
horrible julien g parce que tant de
régions souffrent depuis ce matin je
n'ai pas bien dans les défauts il a
balancé des trois îles à il a
complètement pété impôts contre la zone
de syracuse ouais c'est un genre que
j'aime bien c'est un joueur que j'aime
bien déjà l'année dernière je l'avais a
par moments dans mon top 60 en tant que
junior il est revenu
l'absence de flines elle a énormément
énormément influencé négativement
parce que c'est un joueur qui était à
l'aise sur du pick n pop sur des choses
comme ça le tir c'est pas une arme
incroyable pour lui mais il est capable
d'en mettre
donc c'est donc il était utilisé par mme
alleva dessus aussi quand il était
sophomore et jouer avec
john mcdonald le grand frère de john qui
jouent ils vont hornet et donc si je
voulais jouer il vous et 3,4 en fait
cette perle a été super un super
intéressant oui c'est un jour un peu
haut le world tour est bonne mentalité
je trouve et je pense que ce gars là il
va faire de la g-league il va avoir deux
une chance de va lui donner la chance de
savants nba alors prendre acte qu'ils la
saisissent il en aura pas une énorme
il en aura pas énormément mais je pense
qu'il aura ses chances de se montrer
quand même parce que c'est un joueur
c'est un cursus complet il a de
l'expérience il s'est un peu tous fichés
rien d'exceptionnel c'est un peu
problématique n'a pas une spécialité qui
pourrait développer en nba en tant que
back up mais c'est un joueur très sympa
à suivre
est-ce que moi moi j'aime moi vu que
vous mais oui mais les semblait que de
quelques fois ils étaient un petit peu
dans le dosage de l'effort on va dire
que c'est pas quelque chose qui peut un
peu le limité si pour les scouts nba qui
le regardaient tu veux dire au niveau
défensif
ouais c'est à dire à faire vraiment
l'impression que il préserve ses il ya
un côté un peu minimaliste dans la
production quelques fois par mois j'ai
eu ce sentiment là c'est peut-être que
moi
c'est une limite du à son physique aussi
c'est plus par rapport à sa demande le
physique en fait on en parlait souvent
la callas de l'année dernière on
s'demande
enfin c'est la question que je pose est
souvent haleine pour savoir s'il était
assez rapide pour la nba et en le voyant
encore stan et moi je pense que au
niveau de la vitesse et tout ça devrait
aller parce qu'il a des c'est un gars
qui arrive avec se déplacer malgré son
gros corps et le le combo corps massif
et vitesse il peut être intéressant que
je pense problème vient après il joue
beaucoup 1d beaucoup sur le terrain et
il est impliqué en défense sur la donc
peut-être qu'il ya des moments où en
fait je pense que les moments où il est
proche mais comment dire il laisse le
jeu jouer c'est c'est qu'il sait que le
jeu se passe fin qui déambulent quoi en
fait donc il sait que l'on cherche le
soutien
jordan chacal de l'autre côté donc voilà
et sinon c'est un gars qui reste actif
au contraire en défense c'est un type
qui a des mains et hyper active il est
c'est un bond à un bon vouloir de
ballons qui dans le dans le un contre un
tu vois et qui va qui va qui va partir
en contre attaque c'est un bon joueur de
contre attaque aussi malgré sa masse qui
peut tu as l'impression qu'il peut pas
courir et court et il est capable de
finir sur des gars carrément et j'étais
capable d'emporter des gaous drive allen
cet accord avec moi il peut or il est à
quand tu as dit expérimenté si les 4
années à la fois qui a traîné titulaire
quasiment tout le temps titulaire ça
n'est là et émergents de la conf
si je me rappelle bien même qu'il assure
t il a été dans la hall du fansub team
et dans la all team global
donc ça c'est une tête d'affiche de la
conférence je vois un peu ce que tu dit
pierre sur certains c'est là
certainement en fait je trouve que
l'eeepad tient un peu de il file à un
beau design japonais au chaland oui
c'est exactement ce que le brouillard
s'est déclarée l'impression qu'il y
laisse en effet à quoi aurait il un body
language un peu demain un peu nonchalant
par moments
ce qui suit pas mal nous a peut être un
petit peu agressant pour les mais c'est
un mais c'est un vrai jour de collectif
comme tous les jours de san diego cette
voie là qu'il faut dire aux gens ce
n'est pas une fois qu'ils recrutent des
tops prospects par une foi qui recrutent
des wadden donne donc cédé une vraie
femme qui forme des joueurs qui font
condé bonne carrière après en pro en nba
pour certains pas pour tous mais avant
tout je pense que tu en dis c'est avec
julien 3,4 c'est impossible qu'il faut
pour se prend un biais c'est utile on a
joué une pièce assez pour ça j'ai
présenté en costume quatre mois ouais ce
sera un poste 4 qui tire il faudra qu'il
tire ou alors qu'ils jouent avec un
poste 5 qui lui est un et un stress frey
mais ça sera le seul nom shooter 2 sur
le terrain sauf s'ils arrivent à
s'améliorer sur ce sursaut sur ce plan
alors moi j'ai une petite comparaison
avec lui vous élire se disait quoi il
fait un peu penser à anthony la lg
présenté les dernières devaient remonter
qui joue maintenant qu'à tout est chez
les roquettes en 4 x est un peu de
recevoir deux profils aussi 3 4 qui peut
mettre des points parce passer un moment
l'embêter non plus plus qu à roanne
c'est ce qu'on est vraiment vraiment par
une ciel mitchell est peut-être plus
haut le ranch trop mais ouais c'est dans
le bus dans le corps et pousse et c'est
assez intéressant comme comparaison
sinon à avec un européen que vous prenez
bien vous avez gâché à bout à bout c'est
légal gershon est un peu plus grand j'ai
l'impression des fois il a annoncé sous
les 2 mettront peut-être du tout toi tu
as été un 98 regardons 1/6 6/4 chaîne il
doit faire 2 2 8 a beau comme la même
après la même morphologie du corps est
la même morphologie aussi la même façon
de se déplacer avec la capacité à
changer d'appuis assez rapidement j'ai
l'impression c'est clair
hugon attendu ouais bah écoute
non c'est un joueur que j'aime bien ce
que je vais vous lui reprochez surtout
en fait c'est que ce truc qui se passent
pas sur ses forces ce jour là t'as un
mec qui est très très efficace près du
panier ont sonné à 3 74% de réussite
près du cercle
donc on est quand même très très haut
niveau et c'est quoi c'est un cinquième
de ses tirs alors qu'à côté de ça il va
prendre énormément de poulet mi-distance
moi ça me rend ouf et ses poulains mi
distance
ils viennent jamais de passes décisives
il les force inter - 10% là de deux tirs
pris avec des passes décisives et donc
voilà c'est un jour qui devrait aller
plus près du panier et qu'en fait tu as
l'impression qu'ils s'arrêtent pour
prendre ce tir qui est pas un bon tiers
pour lui alors qu'à côté de ça c'est un
mec quand il va au cercle il génère très
souvent des fautes et c'est là dessus
qu'on bat landreau attendront nba ça va
être un jour de rôle et son rôle à lui
ça va être de mettre de l'impact je
pense tu rajoutes catch and shoot à
trois points des écrans et mettre de
l'impact près du panier et c'est pas
pour ses poules up mi-distance l'acquis
pro de façon exorbitante
on va aller le raf tesmec la nba n'aura
pas les prendre c'est ça il aura pour
aller prendre après tout on peut se
demander aussi pourquoi il avait cette
section de tir là puisqu'elle s'est pas
dû aussi au fait que personne d'autre
pouvait poulet dans cette équipe sans
flynn en fait parce que même le les
meneurs en fait
terrell gomez tout tout tout petit
joueur qu'il avait récupéré à 2 une
autre phase californienne s'étaient
surtout du catch and shoot et très peu
liam c'est un meneur qui sait pas tirer
donc pas de personnes peu de couleur
dans l'équipe par lui à mi distance
c'est clair que c'est sale et s'est
passé pato vient de la fin sur notre ami
michel parce que j'étais assis dans fait
le joueur préféré de maths mitchell
c'est pour ça que fait-il à coudre il
était à fond sur le basket c'était
carmelo anthony est en fait il a
il voulait jouer pour un syracuse en
fait quand il était jeune c'était tu
vois c'est vrai du coup il s'est
rattrapé jouer avec eux voilà les a fait
gagner
donc pour ceux qui ont je sais pas qui
ont péri deux matches du premier tour de
la march madness
san antonio s'est fait sans diego state
s'est fait balayer par syracuse ils ont
pris un mur sur la défense de zone quoi
toi direction l'oklahoma pour parler
d'un meneur de grande taille
ah ouais mais là on est sur un profil
physique un peu différent de maths
mitchell donc on va pas l'être d'austin
wings donc effectivement garde de
l'oklahoma dans la victoire
c'est un senior qui a fait cinq ans
l'art est sûre tu as des lacs transfert
entre wichita state et oklahoma
donc si je dis pas de bêtises il était
backup de certains roms baker et fred
veine bits dans le dans les années 2000
16 à peu près donc
oklahoma forte place de la victoire qui
est une forte conférence à la conférence
dont 10 pour la dernière fois avec bill
alors de marque weiten et cetera
conférence cette enquête que nîmes gamme
du coup rossi se déplacer pour toi sinon
j'en parlais pas de quelques lignes
gamme donc autres facs de l'oklahoma la
moins bonne des deux pour faire plaisir
donc austin reed c'est le patron de
cette équipe ce d'oklahoma qui a pas mal
de bons joueurs qui a retourné pas mal
de gars 1 il va jouer à côté de deux
autres gardes harmon des viandes est
aussi équipe son mojo il a un pivot dans
l'équipe avec qui peuvent eux beaucoup
de pick up up donc c'est un jour qu'on a
vu on a des situations pick and roll
pick and pop
et donc voilà son point fort c'est que
même s'il ressemble à un facteur c'est
un gardien haendel tic deux jours de
pelé grande tu vois des quartiers de
quartier new yorkais saint-wendel
formidable c'est un crossover hyper
smooth c'est un joueur qui est excellent
pour casser le rythme et créé un
décalage avec des appuis qui peuvent
s'étendre très très loin il peut aller
très très vite au cercle et qu'un
service mais comme ça c'est un meneur
qui va jouer pour la passer par un
excellent passeur mais c'est un gars qui
va beaucoup allaient pénétrer et faire
du drive in teak pour ressortir sur ses
shooteurs donc simple on pourrait le
voir un niveau supérieur aux
professionnels il va pas se baser sur
des qualités athlétiques supérieures
donc moi j'aime bien les joueurs comme
ça qu'ils peuvent c'est que tu peux
avoir une carrière un peu plus longue
que ce soit en nba ou en europe par
exemple
après voilà je sais pas sur quel point
tu veux partir chanson je moi je te
laisse moi c'est des finances tu ne l'as
pas trop mal vendu au niveau des plus
tôt on va côté négatif on va dire dû
voir donc les qualités athlétiques s'il
a compris défensivement ça donne quoi
défensivement déjà l'idée font presque
jamais sur le meilleur porteur de balle
adverse
donc c'est pas lui qui va qui va aller
se faire les meneurs en fait s'il a un
pont de réaction moi ce que je trouve
particulièrement lent sur les
changements de rythme donc lui lyrics
père pour casser le rythme mais dès qu
on lui casse le sien baril se
retrouvaient à dix kilomètres et puis
bah voilà il n'est pas signé on n'a pas
un physique ridicule on est à fait de
dire ça je crois que je vais à 93 kg 93
kg mais c'est facilement fond c'est
quand même alors il est grand mais il
n'est pas non plus très impactant ont
peu à l'image d'un tu vois un atome à
satin rose qui ont un billet est par
exemple qui allen co scénarise 7 inspire
on
j'aime bien moi c'est vraiment une
lettre présentée penser c'est le scoreur
un siècle lorsque se gagne
il est il est fait pour il a le jeu fait
pour mettre des points ancien alors
qu'il n'a pas du tout le plus le groupe
pedigree de son équipe savoir quel
d'evionnaz wonder qui vient de se
présenter à la draft
c'est un mec qui a fait signe aux essais
chez les jeunes c'est un joueur qui
était très très côté quand les camps les
américains font médaille d'or au
championnat du monde u17 c'est lui le
meneur titulaire à côté du challenge
green dans 5 c'est lui qui gère un gros
gros tacle sur kylie a nice day je pense
que l'uimm plaisir le combler ses débuts
narbonne qui défend par malheur les
meilleurs guarda diverses
je pense cette année la bataille non
seulement il a le rôle du meneur soit et
je trouve que c'est un vrai bon joueur
que ces pourcentages à trois points
soupe à fond par étapes du shooteur
qu'il est j'ai l'impression que les gens
regardaient pourcentage crois qu'il est
dans les bacs et 30% à chaque fois alors
que je pense que c'est parce que c'est
un joueur qui prend part elles deux
tiers compliqué c'est le joueur qui
prend les deux se compliquer de l'équipe
démena own c'est un mec qui prend des
paroles de mes distances et où jack
gibson le transfert de north texas de
croix c'est un genre qui est très utile
mais sur quatre jeux de shoot plus tôt
puis c'est le système c'est le créateur
ses deux meneurs
moi j'aime beaucoup d'ailleurs gelé j'ai
vu que je crois que jonathan givonne il
avait mis le deuxième tour de sa son
dernier big board sait comment ça va
peut-être avoir une publicité un peu
puisé dans les récentes pensé un jour
qui que pas mal de gens vont aller
revoir parce que c'était les serveurs
cac et plus âgés c'est un joueur qui est
qu'elle n'était pas énorme au creusot
glee était peut-être un peu passé sous
les radars on parle on va voir quelqu'un
leur dise de lui a donné envie d'aller
revoir pas mal de matches un must c'est
un joueur qui sait un jour qui aura
comme mike mitchell je pense que ces
deux joueurs qui auront la chance en
summer league et pourquoi pas sur la pré
saison tout aide de ce mot crise c'est
un mec qui peut mettre des ponts après
défense immense et c'est très compliqué
moi je trouve ouais moi c'est un joueur
que j'ai eu l'occasion de découvrir je
voulais regarder justement quelques
nigam pour pas paraître pour un ignorant
et j'ai découvert c'est un leurre du
match oklahoma state et contre oklahoma
et j'ai découvert recevoir tipi de
basket
clairement je me suis dit ce gars là il
suit de basket 86 % aux lancers francs
ouais effectivement aller à 30% à 3
points mais il prend beaucoup de tirs
difficiles donc on peut aussi dire que
ça va bien meilleur footer que les stats
le montre moi j'ai beaucoup aimé se voir
là donc du coup après je me suis mis à
suivre les sooners d'un peu plus près
donc voilà je lui dirai ce que tu l'as
vu toi bien sûr de lui comme d'un contre
4 kg en gamme et puis un puits pour les
pour le premier toit de la march madness
j'ai pas de bêtises je sais parler des
est exactement mais alors moi vous avez
parlé de facteurs de ce que vous avez
dit d'autre moi j'ai l'impression qu'il
ressemble à ton cousin qui veut pas
aller chez tabac me convient felice la
classe de terrain s'est dit mais il est
pas content d'être à pied 20 secondes
après il va sortir une belle passe un
shoot au shoot et c'est vrai que là le
décalage entre ce que tu vois tu as
l'impression visuelle que tu vois quand
il shoote et pendant le match et quand
tu vas voir les stats d un décalage est
vrai que 30% à 3 points quand tu ne vois
certains matches mais des gros shoots
comme ça c'est le décalage mais tu as a
confirmé pascal m allen disait c'est que
des veines des ternes ramon il est à 97
% de tyrans catch and shoot à trois
points
là-haut l'huile et à 40% de tir en cas
de chute donc voilà c'est que
majoritairement cdd gros pull up et en
plus il a ce truc de alors moi ça j'aime
pas mais quand il va pouleur pour fait
il se jette en avant il ya le corps qui
part très en avant parce qu'il va
chercher la faute aussi et il entre dans
la loge du bras et même les lieux par
yvan s'allonger en avant et donc voilà
ça peut casser le jeu est donc un
travail là dessus et qui prend les trucs
les plus difficiles de l'équipe pierre
est-ce que ça t'inspire ça a l'air
d'être un potentiel à un mec sur qui on
va mettre une petite pièce peut-être le
lui donne et ouais je sais pas peut-être
comment il se comporte moi ce qui
m'intéresse et son passing et vu que il
est il est quand même beaucoup plus
grand que ses opposants
est-ce qu'il en profite de sa taille
pour pour distribuer bah ouais en fait
il va je te dise il existe beaucoup sur
drive and click ça ils aiment bien il va
vraiment pénétré il va ressortir très
fort qu'il est capable de passer à une
mince toujours intéressant mais à trois
niveaux y passe je n'allais pas
l'envoyer en direct sur loeb et puis
voilà après c'est un choix qui quêtent
expérience qui a pris l'habitude je dois
quoique à des connexions la la bralima
d'acoustique et adoption d un trader
viège et comme je disais peut-être plus
tôt possible
quel rôle cusano nba est ce que ce genre
de mec là tu lui donnes le ballon
directement qu'une seconde unité
moi je pense pas ça sera ça s'obtient tu
vois que j'ai du respect pour avoir le
ballon et vu sa taille on pourrait se
dire peut-être qu'ils veulent le faire
jouer en deuxième arrière et c'est là
dessus que je vais être très très
attentif à ce qui va pouvoir exister
loin du ballon dans une équipe où il y
aura des meilleurs blogueurs enfin que
lui je lisais une précision a dit malek
ben ali malek c'est le post 4 fuyant
leurs victimes étaient des grands pics n
pape avec triangle à l'époque de la
saison fraîchement entré en jeu l'équipe
de l'homme kruger beaucoup de kiné drive
in teak mais jouer comme ça plaît donc
si je tue le temps comme ça ça sert une
coach qui va qu'ils y aient plus coach
parce qu'il a pris sa retraite mais
c'est une légende initiés c'est un crime
clôture octroie aurait une bille et
toute l'équipe joue comme ça et ses
joueurs
il arrive comme à trouver souvent des
rôles de rugby en tant que spécialiste
sauf triangle bien sûr mais ces décès
les jours qui s'est très
c'est ça c'est un des jeux les plus qui
transpose le plus sec de la nba on voit
bien pire en essais en vol sur cette
news de chez moi
hugo laisse le mot de la fin pour austin
with bafouent leur garder ce joueur faux
plafonds cas pour garder sa tête après
faut regarder son basket et puis c'est
smooth quoi c'est une leçon de basket et
c'est très très drôle à regarder
n'aurait pas dit mieux on va finir ce
podcast avec la partie quasi pédagogique
à landstuhl mais son jeu grill afin
qu'ils nous expliquent deux dates
avancées que son nom lui et j'ai et le
toucher thing qu'est ce que ces stades
veux le dire comment les interpréter
professeur alan nou té couteau la
pression des piles ou centric séquelles
au cerveau
non mais c'est intéressant parce que
souvent on fait il ya déjà pas mal des
gens sur twitter qui qui doit les stats
avancer c'est compliqué ou 5 s'est pas
encore totalement et perdre démocratiser
alors que si on fera des super super
compliqué en temps à des quêtes d'aidé
plus simples qui sont trouvables
d'ailleurs gratuitement parce que
certaines sont pas 3 ou gratuites moi
non plus mais tu en as des gratuits qui
permettent de de bons petits pas
vraiment moi de faire un tri sur pas mal
de prospects et c'est c'la rapport taux
d' usage trop shooting octobre usage
c'est une statistique
c'est extrêmement compliqué de calculer
combien de jeux pour combien de temps un
joueur à laval la chose la plus la plus
proche est parfaite qu'on a réussi à
faire ces taux d'usagé quand il est à 26
posant ça veut pas dire que le joueur à
26 % du temps la balle c'est plus c'est
une serre mécanisme surtout sur la les
jours qui finissent les actions et
qu'ils ont la balle un pourcentage de
temps important dans une possession mais
c'est ce qui se rapproche le plus d'un
calcul de qui a la balle sur le terrain
le trou shooting c'est pourtant une stat
super super importante
c'est en gros une espèce de somme une
loi mathématique pour qui fait un mix et
pourcentage trois points deux points et
lancers francs donc ça ça permet
vraiment d'avoir un bon en bon calcul de
l'adresse d'un joueur après on va me
dire qu'est ce qu'un bon footing
alors ça dépend c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant d'en parler c'est à dire que
les intérieurs souvent ont souvent un
très bon trou shooting est ce que les
tirs sont plus simple donc entre ajouté
1 go dessus des 60 % c'est un très bon
trou shooting intro shooting en dessous
des 45 % c'est que c'est que c'est pas
trés trés bon piqué boston pendant pas
mal de temps je crois qu'il a pas fini
d'être est aujourd'hui lé té dans les 40
%
elle s'est passé pas quelque chose de
très très beaux est ce qu'on essaye de
voir que c'est un joueur et c'est le
rapport donc luzech couche l'outing si
on a un taux d'usagé
chéhab en porteur de balle il va être
entre 20 et 25 et 30% et qu'on a un trou
shooting au dessus des 50 cent pour cent
je dirais que c'est un c'est qu'on est
sur un prospect subi un procès qui
pourra jouer une bille c'est quand on
regarde pas mal de ses deux séjours là
les meilleurs en nba les khairi james
harden dahmani l'architecte curie c'est
les ovni mais il y avait trop juste il y
en ait trop shooting même parfois au
dessus des 60 % tout en étant à 30% du
jeune c'est des choses assez irréel mais
rensing
niveau est un peu moins bon et que quand
tu es un tour propre père allemand tüv a
dominé 6 teintes rouges footing au
dessus des salles et cinq ans 55% et 40
aux usages entre 20 et v entre 20 et 30
parce que on va tenir au tas de certains
jours on peut imposer qu'ils n'auraient
plus la balle que d'autres c'est là
quelques nigam n'a pas non plus un taux
d'usagé variable alors que il aurait dû
en avoir un tour mais donc cesser c'est
une manière simple si les gens voilà
essayé de calculer l'efficacité d'un
jean d'une certaine montée ça sert
surtout à regarder l'efficacité d'un
joueur en réalité ils efficaces plus
utile s'il n'est pas efficace forrest
faut essayer de comprendre pourquoi une
stat avancer c'est une stat mais ça je
dois jamais faire loi à 100% sur la
visualisation il ya le contexte de
l'équipe qui doit amener c'est ce qui
fait le travail de ba2 ce qu'on fait
nous tous ici c'est beaucoup de
retourner des matches
regardez les stats essaient de comparer
mais si on veut c'est de comprendre si
un potentiel porteur de balle en nba
peut être utile de 7,7 ces deux stats la
mise en corrélation je pense que c'est
un bon début pour les les gens qui
voulaient c'est un peu dans la recherche
de compréhension de sa super messieurs
est ce que vous êtes des questions par
rapport à ces notions de liège et de
trousses shooting pour moi c'était super
clair
moi j'ai comme moi j'ai compris que ça
lui servait à insulter accueilli de
façon indirecte
non ça c'est une mutation oklahoma state
c'est une équipe que j'écrivais beaucoup
trop regarder je pense trop regarder sur
le gard tous trop d trop certaines
équipes cetc présente pour un genre
qu'on colle anthony l'an dernier on
regarde on regarde regarde le taux dix
agents vers le trou shooting c'est pas
bon je pensais pas c'est pas bon ici
mais si on va la visualisation après on
comprend que bon personne d'autre
pouvait prendre les deux poules up donc
le taux d'usagé augmenté personne
personne d'autre pouvait vraiment tirs à
trois points et quand ils pénétraient il
avait deux troncs d'arbres
en face et de troncs d'arbres à lui donc
c'était ça faisait baisser cette
pourcentage donc c'est un joueur qui
était un petit peu moins dans la
quelqu'un qui avait des satins peu
m'importe par contre si on garde un
certain intérieur comme le local gaza où
d'autres jarnac ont des trous footing et
c'est irréel
on va t'il fait des fois que j'ai un
petit peu nuancée par ça c'est juste
pour expliquer cette petite cette petite
nuance mais elle est appliquée qu'elle
est un incroyable défenseur je dirais je
parlerai pas de son jeu offensif je
laisserais hugues développer
prochainement dans une trémie notre
podcast avec les séries messieurs on va
s'arrêter là julien pierre lannes merci
pour la participation
on va remercier les auditeurs nous avoir
écoutés hésitez pas à commenter poser
vos questions liker et partagez le
massivement je vous rappelle aussi
d'aller régulièrement son site envergure
coincé au pour les consulter les stats
lire les derniers articles et scouting
report et les big board
on se retrouve très vite pour un
prochain épisode de dirt 2 les gars
donne serait un soutien et un giga